sûr qu'ils vont se marrer voilà à
pédales dire les gabriel aghion et
michèle laroque garde armand dany boon
jacques dupont voit la sortie le 20 au
score alors michel vous après la vie en
rose après [ __ ] douce le placard
[ __ ] dure ça vous excite les non mais
c'est vrai que je fais un petit bilan là
je me demande pourquoi j'ai fait tant de
films autour de ce sujet je pense que je
pense que c'est parce que ça parle de la
différence c'est que que j'aime bien
justement la tolérance et j'aime bien
quand on trouve intéressant la
différence mais voilà c'est pour ça que
j'étais attiré par ce scénario là un
essai c'est vrai que j'ai lille godrèche
vous a appelé juste avant le tournage
pour venir de vous méfier de de danic
c'était un mec très égoïste elle est
tombé sur moi donc déjà en couple c'est
moi qui ai décroché moi je dors pas car
c'est moi mais vous il ya un truc c'est
que vous avez raconterez d'amour sur un
sur un plateau de tournage avec judith
vous pensez que ça peut arriver avec
gérard aussi c'est arrivé avec gerald
accord oui pareil
oui on continue à être très très
sèchement très proche du tout prévu dans
le scénario
alors évidemment [ __ ] dure c'est
beaucoup plus violent que [ __ ] douce
c'est l'intrusion de de bertrand blier
qui fait ça c'est beaucoup moins sympa
c'est beaucoup moins gay friendly c'est
violent ça veut dire quand tu dis
gayfriendly c'est à dire ce serait
montrer les homosexuels comme ils ont
envie d'être vu c'est ça oui voilà dany
boon vous êtes né le 26 juin 66 ans
armentières
non mais c'est un peu c'est un peu quand
même là
c'est bon
c'est rien c'est pour une télé régionale
au fil des caméras ce qui concerne le
cinéma maintenant tu joue dans la cour
des grandes
thierry pardon je voulais pas de couper
un jeu c'est qu'il ya quand même une
suite d'une collision qui est tout à
fait d'accord il ya quand même une
collision entre la folie douce deux
avions et la folie dur de haguenau et
prochain one man show
en un sens ça me fait plaisir que vous
me posez cette question laurent parce
que justement ça va se faire la main
tenant à êtes en écriture on peut le
dire et votre caméra sur nous
c'est vrai qu'elle est tellement bien
que ces précieux documents c'est vrai
dit sur la question
donc la question c'est qu'il ya une
collision entre la folie douce d'avion
et la folie dur d'oublier en 1989 vous
monter à paris
les premiers boulots la période très
difficile très dur de galère où je
faisais pas de télé régionale et non
c'est vrai ça dit quoi non les sujets
qui font pas sentir bien un truc dans ce
film c'est une colline l'émission elle
est diffusée dans l'émission direct
nous on est sur le régional non mais
c'est vrai que les sujets abordés sont
rarement bien oui la région des manières
sur les sujets abordés sont des sujets
plus lourd
le dvd du chantier à bagdad pour
armentières beaucoup de sujets de mise
en place d'un tiers or les rapports
homos hétéros les rapports hommes/femmes
enfin des des sujets de société quoi
c'est vrai ses oreilles dany ses
oreilles cet endroit de carrière une
malle vent marin on avait dit par ici
gérard et dany c'est la première fois
que vous jouez des homosexuels oui comme
ça oui oui moi je fais une fois avec
danses et la robe en soie a bien pu se
passer dans notre belle région
non les choses là il est sympa je
connais gérard izany j'ai l'impression
michel spécialisé un peu dans les films
homo mais c'est la première fois qu'on
est que ce soir c'est la première fois
que vous jouez donc tous les deux des
rôles d'homosexuels oui ou non non moi
dans un film de jugnot j'ai déjà fait ça
une fois mais c'était plutôt une
caricature était sans reproche une
caricature il a là c'est vraiment vous
quoi là c'est vraiment moi et puis il ya
eu cet accident de voiture qu'il aurait
agit donc tout le monde
il a été alors ça vous plairait dans la
vie je vais essayer d'en révéler ces cas
là qu'en journée de cette réponse que de
ce que répond dutronc c'est à dire que
je pense que je n'essaierai jamais parce
que imagine que j'aime et que j'adore ça
mais le temps que j'aurais perdu
ouais c'est vrai donc je passe rien mais
depuis que vous avez fait le film avec
dany vous vous prenez des douches avec
les potes
après le sport on vous a un petit peu
modifiée non s'est il m'arrive de laver
des deux genres dont il pensait la
moustache dany maintenant ça se voit
c'est seulement va-t-elle presse ça
pousse pas j'aime bien ce côté imberbe
moindre oubli dans rabbi jacob
celle avec les riches hommes c'est
l'inoubliable crois qu'on va voir un
extrait
mais il ya un moment même où vous vous
êtes dit tous les deux si c'était vrai
qu'on vive ensemble oui non pas où je
pense je pense pas plus haut enfin je
vois que ça ça fait un peu de peine à
nice que je veux que oui il ya un moment
où j'ai vu avait réellement visé parce
que j'aime encore un peu toi y'a quand
même c'était le michel ta fleur préférée
et la cheville droite et vous amis
devant le juge pas léguer voudrez
et vous dany non c'est pire après vous
seriez open pour des plans à trois mais
comment je peux écrire des conneries
open pour des plans 23 quelle est ta
couleur préférée dany parce que je suis
sur notre chaîne ça c'est de gérard
album s'est très bien vendu et suave et
si tu n'es pas tu n'étais pas un
chanteur d'occasion à un vrai chanteur
du chapare un deuxième album absolue
john elway ce niveau là voilà c
enregistrés j'en suis là après après le
film que je te là je vais tourner je
vais faire mon deuxième album et la
tournée bientôt et armentières peut-être
sûrement chèrement sûrement chez vous
adressez vous à armentières la tyrie je
te rend l'antenne
merci laurent michel dans la vraie vie
vous partiriez avec lequel les deux sur
une île déserte et levier ou le légume
pas facile hein
c'est vrai ce qu'il soit apparue sur les
télés régionales je peux pas avec lequel
vous pourriez dormir dans le même lit
sans me glace quoi que ce soit quelque
chose sont marqués par le film c'est lui
qui a le plus marqué un but ce qu'il a
pris vraiment que dominique segall va
être content de la promotion vous venez
de faire la queue je crois qu'il va être
extrêmement content trois demandes hier
c'est très bon mari je sais parce que le
film parle de lui-même de moins donc on
en parle et qu'on est sur ce film vous
avez très bien résumé la situation
sa série tous les trois on sait que
c'est un couple pacsé qui est qui qui
désirent un enfant qui aimait repos
qu'une mère je pense que voilà qu'à
leurs essais cdc de la comédie moi je
trouve que la réunion des deux de
l'univers de blier qui était qu'elle est
très très acide et qui a un regard comme
ça oui sur l'homosexualité c'est assez
pathétique et alors il est il ya aussi
le pathétisme daguillon qui lui le le
transmet avec le rire il aime bien la
comédie il aime bien
un peu comme c'est rare un peu comme ces
travestis qui sont tout à fait maquiller
quantis démaquille en dessous ce matin
faire un plus rebelle il m'informe merci
armentières 1 voilà après leur est bon
c'est laisser l'envié ou non du du
public je pense que sanaa ce n'est pas
du tout la suite je crois de [ __ ]
douce c'est le deuxième volet de [ __ ]
douce
ces neuf ans après le monde homosexuel à
bouger à changer la société a changé
c'est autre chose
alors c'est peut-être un peu plus
grinçant que le premier effectivement
ils en parlent bien non on est quand on
laisse parler quand armentières
tout ça sera coupée au montage